hello and welcome to building robust
graph QL api's with AWS amplify and AWS
app sync my name is Nader dabit I work
on the AWS mobile and AWS amplify team
and I am a developer advocate and what
we're going to be going over today is
really kind of a deep dive on how you
can actually use the amplifi library
along with app sync to add a lot of
functionality with not a lot of work not
a lot of code and also kind of how to
understand how to add the types of
functionality that go past's really the
hello world type of application and into
something more production-ready more
real-world more of the types of
applications that you'll end up building
once you kind of get the basics down so
what should you expect from the session
this is kind of going to be what we're
going to be going over we're first going
to do an overview a general overview of
AWS amplify once we are done getting an
understanding of amplify we're gonna
then take a look at AWS app sync we're
not gonna dive too deep into exactly
what app sync is we're going to assume
that you kind of already have that
decent understanding of that but we will
give a general overview of AWS at sync
well then talk about the graph QL
transform library and really the entire
talk today is really going to be focused
around this library and we're gonna talk
about what exactly it is but in general
essentially it is a bunch of directives
a bunch of decorators that you can add
to your graph QL schema and then using
the amplifi CLI you can add
functionality to your graph QL API we'll
walk through all of the graph QL
transform directives that are available
and talk about what each one of them
does well then jump into a live demo
where we'll use all of the different
directives that we went over in the
previous portion of this presentation
and actually build out and test a real
graph QL API some of the things that
we're going to be going over today or
how to add authorization rules to a
graph QL API we're going to look at how
to add relationships so one-to-many and
many-to-many relationships into your
graph QL API
we're also gonna look at how to add
different types of keys to your database
that's going to be generated by the
graph QL transform library so if you
need to do things like sorting if you
need to do things like specifying your
global secondary index or even your hash
key we're gonna look at how that you can
do that using the graph QL transform
library and then finally we're going to
look at how to use the very powerful at
model directive and this is kind of the
base level directive that gives us all
of this other functionality that
generates a lot of the different data
bases resolvers and additional schema
that we're going to be using all right
so let's keep on going now what is
amplify
so if you're here you probably already
have a general understanding but if not
we'll give a quick overview it's a CLI
in a tool chain for the client and
there's also the amplify console which
we're not covering here but the amplify
console is a hosting platform the CLI is
a command-line interface of course and
it allows you to create and configure
AWS services directly from your
front-end environment or from your
terminal or from cloud 9 also it also
consists of a JavaScript library or a
client library in general if you're
using native iOS or native Android and
once you've created your services from
the CLI you can use one of these client
libraries to then interact with the
services that were created by the CLI so
what kind of services are supported we
continually are adding new services so
for example we very recently added
machine learning and AI services but in
general this is kind of a very good
overview of what you can do with amplify
right now you can add databases you can
add different types of api's both both
graph QL and API gateway with lambda you
can generate lambda functions you can
also add authentication analytics
hosting storage via s3 and chatbots and
there's a few other utilities that are
part of the amplified client library on
the front end that don't really have any
specific AWS services on the back end
like internationalization
so let's take a look at a couple of the
services that we're going to be using
today for authentication we're going to
need to specify authentication rules on
our graph QL schema and we're gonna need
to add authorization rules for
interacting with our graph QL API in
general so to do that we're going to
need to set up some type of
authentication service and with amplifi
you can set up authentication using the
API category which under the hood
utilizes Amazon kognito Amazon Cognito
is a user management service and it's
completely managed and what it basically
does is it allows you to sign up users
sign in users that just manage all of
your users and from the CLI you can
create and configure new cameras on
kognito resources from the client
library you can interact with this user
service by signing in signing up and
interacting with different mechanisms
that you would need for user management
we also have pre-configured components
available for JavaScript libraries like
react react native angular and ionic and
we also have pre-configured components
for native iOS and native Android so
after you've created this service you
can use these pre-configured components
to kind of get up and running quickly
with a real user interface the other
service that we're going to be working
with from amplifi is AWS app sync and
it's categorized under the API category
so what as AWS top sync essentially the
general overview is that it's that it's
a managed API service and it utilizes
graph QL as the implementation you can
basically from the CLI do all of these
things so you can create AWS app sync
graph QL api's after you've created your
API you can then continually configure
update and manage your API so the base
schema that you start off with can
evolve and you can evolve your schema
from the command line using the amplifi
client library either on native or
javascript you can then interact with
the app CG API so once the API
there you want to then query against it
you want to send mutations you want to
register for subscriptions you can do
all of that from the client libraries
and then part of the amplifi CLI that
integrates directly with app sync is
something that we're going to talk about
today called the graph QL transform
library and the graph QL transform
library is a series of directives or a
library of directives that allow you to
decorate a base graph QL type to add
additional functionality so what we're
going to be really focusing on here is
how to use the graph QL transform
library so let's take a look at some of
the different transforms that are
available to us the main ones that we're
going to take a look at today or at
model at off at connection and at key we
also have at versioned
at function and at searchable since
we're covering the four that I mentioned
I'll also just go over really quickly
what versioned and ette function and at
searchable do that version allows you to
have versioning in your API of course
just like the name sounds add function
allows you to specify a lambda function
as your graph QL resolver so a lot of
times people would like to implement
microservices or existing other back-end
services that aren't directly accessible
from App sigit at the moment to do that
it's pretty easy to do anything you
would like in a lambda function so a lot
of times people use this at function
resolver to add a lambda function from
there you can write whatever code you'd
like and then have the response turned
returned into graph QL and then we have
at searchable at searchable allows you
to deploy an elastic search instance
using accommodation of at model so
therefore you can have not only the base
search functionality that you would get
out of dynamodb but you extend that to
everything that elastic search and it
integrates directly with the dynamodb
instance so essentially when you create
an operation and you store it in Dona Mo
we also stream that to elastic search so
once the operations are created once the
data is there
you can perform queries either against
dynamodb or elasticsearch once you
delete items from DynamoDB we also
extend and delete those from
elasticsearch so it's kind of like
having two databases available to you
that way
you know a lot of times you're limited
for certain reasons for what you need to
do that isn't available in donna mowers
in some database elasticsearch extends
kind of the functionality and allows you
to perform you know more complex queries
using elastic search but now we're going
to go over at model at off at connection
and at key so at model is a very very
very powerful directive and it's
something that we're going to be using
for pretty much all of our fields and
what it does is it allows you to take a
base type decorate with this at model
field and then we actually then scaffold
out a bunch of different functionality
for you based on a lot of pre-configured
specifications that a lot of best
practices are based upon and a lot of
customer use cases a lot of things that
people do with their api's so for
example crud operations we generate
create read update delete and list
operations and in your graph QL schema
we then create the resolvers that
integrate with those operations and then
we also generate the database and then
also we generate the subscriptions as
well so to use at model you might have a
graphical type that you've created like
this in the past and then you might want
to have an operation like create to-do
update to do delete to do etc
essentially what you've had to do in the
past is define those operations as
either queries or mutations in your
schema you then had to write the
resolver code that interacted from that
operation into your datasource and you
also of course had to set up that actual
data source but if you use graph QL
transform you can just add this at model
decorator this will go ahead and
generate all of that stuff for you you
can then take what we've generated and
modify it
you know whatever business use case
whatever you know data that your
business logic or whatever that your
application needs so we kind of generate
some best practices for you some
boilerplate it works for a lot of use
cases but if you need to extend that you
can go in and easily easily make changes
and then model the different resolvers
and things like that around your own
specifications
so essentially ad model adds create read
update delete the list operations to
your schema it adds a dynamo DB table
it adds the subscriptions and it adds
the resolvers for all of these
operations the next transform we'll take
a look at is at connection so when
people are getting up and running with
graph QL a lot of times people have a
lot of problems getting started creating
relationships between their data so at
ma at connection is basically something
we brought forward to help people get
started much easier with those
relationships and what we end up doing
is allowing to to just specify an @
connection between different types and
what happens under the hood is we do all
of the work of creating the resolvers
and in the possible global secondary
indexes I might need to be created on
the table to do things like searching on
a field or on a on a type within the @
connection so to use this you might have
a growth cool scheme that looks
something like this you have two types
of data that need to have relationships
with each other so here we have a type
of post the post has comments and we
have a type of comment but the comment
doesn't really know about the posts so
how can we make it to where we can
create a post and then create a comment
from within that post and we don't want
to actually have to write all this code
all you need to do is add the @
connection directive and then here you
can give the name of the connection and
then if you'd like to have a sort field
you can specify
as well so here we're adding post
comments as the connection and we're
adding post as the type under comment
and this will automatically generate all
of the necessary resolvers it will also
add a global secondary index in the
table for for the comment table for us
to be able to query based on the ID of
the post so when someone creates a post
someone create a comment under that post
we can then query for comments based on
the post ID so at connection again model
relationships between your data the CLI
will then create the necessary resolvers
based on the @ connection declaration
the next transform we'll take a look at
is at off and this as it sounds will
enables you to add the ability to
specify authentication rules so
authentication is you know one of the
most complex things that you'll probably
run into when building out the business
logic of your graph QL application and
when you're dealing with things in your
resolver so what's the easiest way to
kind of get up and running with some
basic rules well at auth is pretty easy
to get up and running with and it allows
you to have a lot of control and a very
high level of your resolver so take for
instance a base type of post and say for
instance we created a blog application
and we wanted this post to be readable
by everyone but we only wanted the
creator of the post to then be able to
update delete or modify the post how
could we do that without having to you
know write a bunch of code well we can
add the alt directive and then we can
pass in the roles that we would like so
if we passed in the aunt auth directive
and we passed in the the roles property
and we only set allow to owner in this
array and we did not specify queries
null as you see here then only the owner
would be able to read this post but we
can also add additional rules after we
set the allow property so for instance
for a blog application we actually want
everyone to be able to query against
this post and read these posts
so we pass in the queries property we
set that to null so this means that only
the owner can update or delete this post
but anyone can query against this post
therefore we're setting no rules under
the queries and there a bunch of
different ways that you can configure
this in fact you can pass in an array of
different rules so it so for instance
another popular use case is having
different fields that are available
based on the group that the user is in
so if you're an admin we might add
another property to this array that says
allow groups and then we can pass in in
the array of groups that can then access
this this post so if we did pass in and
say an array and we added the admin if
someone was an admin they would also be
able to access this post as well as the
owner so at all there are quite a few
different ways that you can configure
this we check out our documentation you
can get pretty in-depth without you can
model your data here but essentially it
allows you to define authorization rules
and then the last one we're going to
take a look at before we actually build
out our our application is at key and at
key is something we recently added that
enables the ability to configure a
custom index structure for your at model
types so if you've created your database
using app model and you want to specify
things like the hash key you want to
specify things like a certain way that
you want to have a sort key or anything
like that or maybe you want to specify a
global secondary index for you to query
against you can do all of this with with
that key and the way that you might do
that let's say we have an event type and
when someone queries for these events
what we want to happen is we want we
don't want to just get all of the events
back in a random list we don't want to
have to deal with sorting that on the
client we don't want to have to deal
with that but maybe we have an
application that lists events in order
from which they were created so how
could we
have a an API where when we queried
against this API it would list the
events in the order that they were
created so to do that we can add the at
key and we can set a few different
properties first of all you have the
optional ability to set a name and this
name is going to specify the global
secondary index so this isn't going to
be the main index the ID this is instead
going to be a new index that we're
creating called query name and then
we're gonna also have an array of fields
the first field is going to be the
global secondary index that we'd like to
query against the second is going to be
the sort field so we'd like to sort by
created at and then the third argument
is going to be the query field and when
we pass in a query field this is
basically just going to create a graph
QL query that allows us to query using
this additional these additional fields
so we'll have a way to list all events
but we'll also have a way to query
events by date and the query field that
we're creating is items by date so we
can basically then query these items by
date and we'll take a look at how to use
all of these in just a second so
essentially key as a directive that
allows you to configure custom index
structures so how do you use amplify CLI
and do all this stuff we're about to
take a look at how to use it but how do
you install it NPM install - G at AWS -
amplify slash CLI once you've
initialized once you've installed the
CLI you can initialize a new project by
running amplify and it's once you want
to add a new feature after the project
it's been initialized so you could run
amplify add with the name of the feature
what we're going to be doing today is
amplify a doll and then we're going to
be doing amplify add API so alright so
let's go ahead and demo this out now so
I'm gonna go ahead and jump to my
terminal window so here we are in a an
empty folder and what I would like to do
is initialize a new amplified project so
I'm going to run amplify in it and this
is going to walk us through the steps of
initializing a new amplifier project
so I'll go ahead and set some basic
default configuration for this project
I'm not working in a reactor or a view
application so I'm not really worried
about the different build and run
scripts but I'm gonna go ahead and set
the project name and the environment for
now I'll go ahead and set my AWS profile
I'll go ahead and pick us East two and
this is going to go ahead and generate
the base amplified project after we're
done here we'll go ahead and add our our
authentication and then our API alright
so after the amplifi project has been
created we should now see our amplifi
folder so we can now start adding a few
features so the first thing I want to
add is authentication so I'll go ahead
and run amplify add off this is going to
go ahead and walk us through a few
different steps we just want something
really basic because we just want to
test out authentication in our API so
what we're going to do is set the
default configuration we want to be able
to sign in with a username so we'll
choose username and that's really about
it and that will go ahead and set us up
with authentication so the next thing we
want to do is go ahead and get to our
graph QL API so I'll go ahead and run
amplify out API the API we'd like to
build is graph QL
I'll leave the API name as gql transform
and we want to set the authorization
type for this API as Amazon kognito user
pool using the authentication service we
just set up a moment ago which is
implementing Amazon kognito so we can
choose that do we have an annotated
graph QL schema if we did have one we
could choose yes here and just linked to
the path that it was located but we
don't so I'm gonna go ahead and choose
no and this is gonna be where we create
our custom graphic ul schema I'm gonna
go ahead and choose yes to God it's
schema creation and I'm just going to
take any of these projects because we're
basically going to be overriding them
anyway and I'll go ahead and choose yes
to edit the schema
and this should go ahead and open the
graph QL schema and our text editor so
this gives us the base type of to do and
you see that we automatically are giving
this directive of that model and that's
great we're gonna be using that model
but we're gonna be getting a little more
complicated than that
some can go ahead and delete this and
I'm going to talk about the type of app
that we're gonna be building today we're
gonna be building two parts of this API
to kind of demonstrate a couple of
different types of applications that you
can build we're gonna be building one
type of kind of like a blogging app or
you can have a post and then we can have
a comment and then we're also going to
be building an events app so where we
can basically create an event name and
with the events we're going to be using
the @ key directive so we can do sorting
and then for the blogging app for the
post and for the comments we're going to
be implementing authorization and we're
also going to be implementing the
relationships with the @ connection so
the first thing the first type we want
to go ahead and create is post and here
we want to go ahead and add the @ model
because we want to go ahead and generate
the additional schema as well as the
resolvers in the database but we also
want to add at all and for at auth we're
just going to pass in now a roles array
and this roles array is going to specify
exactly what we would like going on to
happen for our authorization rules so
what I want to do is I want to allow the
owner so if the posts was created by me
I want to be able to edit update delete
and also query for it but I also want to
set the queries roles to null because if
I am also a guest user that didn't
create this post I also want to be able
to just read the post and that's kind of
about it everything else is going to be
just basic graph QL fields so I'll go
ahead and give the post an ID a title
and a comments array
and we're gonna get back to this
comments or in just a moment let's go
ahead and create the type of comment and
this is also going to have the app model
field and what we're going to do here is
give the comment and ID we're gonna give
the comment a content and we're also
going to be created at and now we want
to define our relationship between
comments and the comments post so what
we're going to do here is we're gonna
add the comment as the array and then
here we can specify the @ connection and
then at connection is going to have a
name and then it's going to also have a
sort field and the sort field is going
to be created at and we cannot we can
also kind of just copy this and use it
here because what we're going to do is
have a post as the relationship with the
comment and then we can specify the type
of post as the field of post and then we
can add the same connection information
so we also won't post comments as the
name to match this and then we also want
the sort field to be created at okay so
that's our blog this should allow us to
be able to create posts create comments
on the post and the next thing we want
to do is have a type of event and this
event type is going to be a little
different because we want to add the at
key directive here and add some search
capability so what we're going to do is
have an app model and we're also going
to have an app key and we're going to
specify those key rules in just a moment
but first let's go ahead and specify the
fields on this event we want an ID we
want a name
we won't a created at and we're also
going to add a new field called query
name because we want to associate a
consistent field across all of our
events because we're going to be
forming a query against our dynamodb
table as opposed to his scan and for in
order to perform a query we need to be
querying against a field within our our
graph QL type so the field that I'm
going to create this query name and this
is going to be consistently named event
across all of our operations so in the @
key I can now go ahead and specify the
name for the global secondary index that
we're going to create and this is going
to be query name
I'll also define the fields array so the
first item in the fields array is going
to be the global secondary index or the
index that we'd like to to have as the
query and this is going to be the query
name and then the second argument is
going to be the sort field and for us
that's going to be created so the last
thing we want to do is add a query field
and this is going to go ahead and allow
us to define a graph QL query that we'd
like to use using this new query that
we've created to to list items by
created at so how can we query this sort
field basically and for the query field
we're gonna call this items by date this
could also be something like events by
date so now I'm gonna go ahead and save
that and jump back to the command line
so now we should see that the graph QL
schema compiled successfully and I
should be able to go ahead and run
amplify push and this should go ahead
and deploy not only the authentication
but also the graph QL API
now we have the option to generate the
graph QL code locally for our
application if I was building a client
application I would probably choose yes
but I'm since I'm only worried about the
API for this demo I'm gonna go ahead and
choose now
all right now that the graph QL API and
the authentication service has been
created we can now start testing
everything out so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to go ahead and
open up the code and my text editor the
amplifi project and what we're going to
do is we should now see that we have an
AWS - export CAS file that was created
for us and this is essentially just a
key value pair of the different services
that we've created and what I'm kind of
interested in is the client ID because
I'm gonna need to basically sign in to
the grotto API simulating this this
client that we created so I'm gonna go
ahead and copy this and then I'm gonna
go back to the terminal and I want to go
next and create a new user in our
kognito service and the way that we can
do that that is we can run amplify
console off and this will go ahead and
open up the kognito service that we just
created and allow us to go ahead and
create a couple of users I'm gonna go
ahead and choose just a user pool
and this should go ahead and open the
user pool for you to go ahead and
interact with so I'm going to go to
users and groups I'm going to go ahead
and create two new users so the first
one is going to be add Abbott 3
the next user I'll go ahead and create
is
so we've created two new users now we
can interact with our graph QL API by
signing in as one of these two users and
the reason we created two users is we
want to show how the authorization works
how if we create something we try to
access or update something and we're not
that person we should not be able to do
that so so we're done here let's go back
to the command line and now open up our
graph QL API and we can one amplify
console again but here we want to run
amplify console API this should go ahead
and open up the graph QL API
okay great so here we are the first
thing I'm going to do is notice that
we're in the queries section of this API
I want to go ahead and log in with user
pools so I'm gonna go ahead and paste in
the client ID that we copied from our a
double US exports file and I'm gonna go
ahead and sign in as dabit 3 and this
should set us up and let us reset our
password because we set that manually
I'm going to go ahead and reset it and
now we should be good to go so the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to go ahead and create a new mutation of
create post and here we just want to go
ahead and create our first post and if
we're not sure we can go ahead and look
at the documentation for what the post
input entails so we just need to pass in
a title I'll call this post 1 and I'll
just return the ID and the post and the
title actually so post 1 let's go ahead
and create post to post 3 okay so now
that we've created a couple of posts
let's go ahead and list our posts so
let's go ahead and create a query called
list posts and this will be returning an
items array with an ID and a title for
every item in the post array ok great so
everything seems to be working properly
now let's go ahead and sign out and what
we want to do is sign in as another user
so I'm gonna go ahead and sign in as
Lily
and now I'm signed in as a new user you
should notice that we should be able to
go ahead and list all the posts still
because we set queries to null so
there's no different authorization rules
on the query but let's go ahead and try
to update a post that was created by
someone else so I'm going to go ahead
and create a new mutation called update
and this is going to take in an input
that takes the ID of the post and I'm
just going to paste in the ID of the
post that was created by someone else
and I'll return the ID in the title and
then I want to change the title of this
post to post from Lily you should notice
that we get some type of error and we're
getting the conditional check exception
and this is essentially saying that we
cannot make this update because we are
not the person that created this so
let's go ahead and create another post
from me as the current login user and
now let's go ahead and try to update
this post
we're gonna change the title to new
updated post and now when we query for
our list we see that we were able to
successfully modify that post but we
weren't able to do that
using someone else's post so we also so
we've looked at the authorization how
that's kind of working so far let's go
ahead and take a look at our base schema
though for the entire app you notice
that we only created three base types we
created a comment type we created a
event type and we created a post type
but you'll notice that we have all of
this additional schema this is what the
app model directive did it created all
of this additional schema based on the
at model type giving us the mutation
definitions here and the resolvers also
giving us the queries for all of the
crud operations as well as all the
subscriptions so all this stuff that's
kind of already wired up for us the next
thing we might want to do is create a
comment so we can test out the
relationships even further so let's go
ahead and list for posts and let's go
ahead and create a comments
and we're gonna take the input and we're
going to go ahead and see what we need
to do to create a comment so what we
need to do is have an ID account some
content created and comment posts but we
don't need to pass in the ID we only
need a pass in the content we can say
something like great post we then want
to go ahead and comment post ID and this
is going to be the ID of the post that
we're commenting on so we're going to
comment let's say let's comment on post
number three
let's go ahead and try list us again
so I'll go ahead and copy the ID from
here try this again
looks like I'm having trouble copying
this ID so I'll go ahead and just copy
this here for now
oh my god just
let me try listing this one more time
and there we go
okay so let's go ahead and create the
comment and now let's go ahead and list
the post along with the comments so we
also have a feel that we can now get
here and we want to return the items
array from the comments and we just want
to create the we just want to return the
content on any comments so let's go
ahead and list posts again you'll notice
that most of the items come back with an
empty items array except for post three
where we did create one comment so you
see that the relationships are indeed
working and what we can now do is create
comments on a post and that relationship
is all already handled for us so the
last thing we want to do is demonstrate
how we can return a sorted list so what
we're going to do is create a mutation
for a new event because that's the one
thing that we haven't looked at is how
to create an event so what we want to do
is create a list of events and then
query for those events based on the time
that they were created so we're gonna be
working with this create event mutation
and the one thing that we might want to
do though is right now in our query in
our type definition actually in the
event type event type we have a
hard-coded created at and a hard-coded
query name that is a required property
of this and what we might want to do is
if this created at property can be
auto-generated for us on that server in
some in some fashion or maybe we can
just generate this value in the resolver
that will be great that way we don't
have to pass in to create it at because
really as soon as this item is created
it's just going to be doing a
calculation and if we can do that on the
server that will be great the other
value that we might be able to handle
them the resolver is the query name
because the query name is going to be
the same because we're just using this
query name as a way to perform queries
on the global secondary index so let's
go ahead and
and change the resolver by going into
schema looking for the mutation for
creating an event and what we wanted to
is we want to make sure that the creator
that value is auto-generated for us and
also we want to make sure that the query
name value is auto-generated for us now
if you look at the request mapping
template this is what goes and interacts
with our database this is the upper
operation that's going to be setting a
put item essentially in our database
you'll notice that the create event
value is already jet being generated for
us the only thing we really need to is
do is generate the query name and you'll
notice that we have an operation that
adds a new value to our input object
called type name let's go ahead and add
another value called query name and this
is going to go ahead and set all of the
operations that this operation creates
to add a new query name property called
event and we already have the created
add value being saved there so we should
be good to go let's go ahead and save
that resolver go back to our schema and
now we want to look at the create event
input because this is the actual input
that we're passing in we want to make
sure that we're not having any required
values that we don't actually have to
pass in so instead of requiring the
query name instead of requiring created
at let's go ahead and make those
optional in fact we might be able to
delete the query name property since
we're not using it at all I'm go ahead
and save that
now that our scheme has been updated
we'll go back to our queries and will
now create a mutation for creating an
event
so for an events let's go ahead and take
a look at what we now need the only
thing that's required is a name so I'll
just call this event one because we want
to create a bunch of events and show how
we can query for these based on the time
that they were created and for the
return value I'll return the ID the name
and the created at values because will
now see that this created at was
generated for us on the server so
there's a vent one let's go ahead and
create an event two of it three four
five and six okay so we have six events
created let's go ahead and do a basic
query to kind of see how these events
are going to come back and in a random
order and then we're gonna look at how
to bring these back in an ordered
fashion so we wanted to do a query for
list events and list events is going to
go ahead and return an items array and
we'll go ahead and return the name ID
and created it for every one of these
events and here we see that we have
event six event to event three so this
isn't the right order we'd like to have
these events come back into order so
what we can do is now instead of using
this length list events query we can
instead use the items by date query and
what we want to pass in as the argument
for the query name and the the item
query name is event and now let's run
this query again and now you'll see that
we have the events coming back in an
ordered list so we have a vet one event
to event three they're coming back
sorted using that sort key that we
passed then I've created at so now you
can basically model any of these
different types that you are creating in
your graph QL schema and have whatever
sort key that you like so when you start
performing queries against your database
you can have the queries come back in a
order list on the server as opposed to
having to deal with that stuff on the
client well that wraps up this webinar
thank you for for attending if you have
any questions you can reach me on
Twitter I am dabit 3d ABI T number three
on Twitter and thank you for watching